pay attention to moments of change
right so in a dynamic organization like
instagram new stuff is happening all the
time right new products are launching
new markets are launching
those moments of change
are actually incredible opportunities to
learn
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today's
episode is with eliot schmuckler
previously he was the chief growth
officer at instacart where he led the
company through a massive period of
change in hyper growth
prior to that he has held senior product
and growth leadership roles at
fast-growing companies like wealthfront
and linkedin he began his career as an
engineer and product manager at
companies like microsoft and ebay
elliot is a recognized expert on
data-driven product management and
consumer growth strategies in silicon
valley with numerous talks and
publications on these topics he holds a
degree in computer science from harvard
university and an mba from the stanford
graduate school of business today he is
the ceo of anomalo
[Applause]
elliot schmuckler welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from menlo park
california how are you
i'm doing great thank you so much for
having me
no no i know how busy you are and i'm so
excited to have you here elliot
you know um
you've
probably
had
experiences at the top companies in the
world not just from an interesting
interest perspective but also just in
terms of the companies that most people
would want to even experience at some
point whether it's ebay linkedin
wealthfront and instacart as chief
growth officer and and and now anomalo
as a ceo and so
crazy experiences i'm really
really what i want to do is to just
understand you better understand your
journey and the different insights
you've picked up on all the way from
getting your bachelors at harvard to
your mba at stanford so really i mean
there must be so many different nuggets
that i'll extract from you in these 20
minutes so i i just want to start with
your upbringing tell me a little bit
about you as a kid you know are you
what did you envision for yourself
growing up
yeah yeah i didn't envision much
you know
um i think
i'll give you a few formative
experiences from my childhood so one i'm
an immigrant
uh like a lot of folks are that end up
in startups um i was actually born in in
ukraine
wow and i came to the us when i was 10.
and i was just a happy-go-lucky uh you
know person
um but then when i came to the u.s i i
met my cousin who had been here for a
very long time and he introduced me to
computers
and you know i was blown away really in
that first interaction with his
commodore 64.
well peter that's you know that's a
model they had in the 80s
um i heard i heard about that in the
history books
yeah that's right that's right and so it
set me on a path of really trying to
learn as much as i could about computers
and and trying to find every opportunity
to to work with them and play with them
and understand them better and so i
idolized some of the early pioneers the
steve jobs the bill gates
um and so that was that was pretty
formative
and and where were you living back then
i was in new york you were in new york
when we when we came to the us i lived
in new york
uh and only really came out to
california for for graduate school
incredible so tell me a little bit more
how this sort of curiosity
and led you throughout your career your
you get to take part in in these
remarkable companies
what what has sort of been your your
guide in choosing your respective
positions or choosing what you'll be
working on that's always interesting to
me
yeah yeah so at first i just wanted to
code right i just wanted to be energy
so if you look at some of my early jobs
i was just excited to be
coding stuff and making computers do
things uh and building products
um you know through my my technical
efforts but i think it was when i was at
microsoft that i discovered that there
was this other side
to building things uh
product management right we have
engineers right of course microsoft
thousands i don't know maybe it's tens
of thousands of engineers sure
um
but we had product managers and
microsoft called program managers
um
that
were very technical had been former
engineers quite often
but actually got to make the bigger
decisions
about the products that we were building
got to
kind of figure out our strategy and got
to set the priorities
and
i uh you know i was enjoying being here
but i kind of want to do that i kind of
wanted to make the more important
decisions
and have broader scope interesting what
was it about um
what what was it about product
management that really spoke to you
because you know you were mentioning the
fascination with computers and and
making stuff happen yourself and now
you're talking you know there's product
management you have much
different decisions to be making you're
a little bit stepping away from the
nitty-gritty details of coding you're
going into an entire product and and
situational awareness so what was it
really that spoke to you at that point
i just saw the problems that the product
managers were solving as more
interesting problems to solve
i think that was literally it uh you
know you're of course
coding and engineering the ads has lots
of problems and lots of things that you
need to solve but i just
saw the high level problems of
the product managers for solving a
competitive strategy what's what's right
for the user or how do we make this as
simple as possible to use
and i just thought those were more
interesting problems
and interesting they were still
technical in nature they've still kind
of connected
uh to my initial passion
around computers and technology
are there some specific experiences in
that transition to product management
that you particularly remember as
sort of
mind altering for you or giving you new
perspectives and appreciation for this
type of work
yeah yeah so a few um you know
kind of one of the biggest formatting
experiences
i fell in love with product manager i
started working on it up at ebay
as a product manager
but i you know i didn't really know what
i was doing uh and ebay was of course a
great environment where you're
surrounded by lots of great product
managers there's product management
training
and all those kinds of things
but one of the biggest insights um
actually during that time which connects
to what i did today was the power of
data
right i i just thought and at microsoft
this was true the product manager just
made decisions based on you know
first principles thinking
interesting
their perception of the market was
almost like a philosophical system
right and by arguing with their bosses
made yeah right uh interesting because
at by herself that's how a lot of
decisions were made it was based on this
kind of strategic first principles
thinking
and then i was exposed to things during
during business school and also ebay
that showed hey there's another way to
make decisions
which is by using data
and in fact you can collect data
specifically for the purpose of making a
decision that's what an a b test right
is or an experiment you're collecting
data so that you can make a decision
later and and that was really
fascinating
and i just want to make sure i get the
timeline right this is the these are
insights that you have back in grad
school which is quite quite some time
ago right
so so these are and and you know quit
just giving a quick spoiler this is a
part of the essence of what a novello is
in the start that you're that you're
currently running look at it and edit
enterprise data but but
we'll stick to the timeline for now and
then connect the dots so
yeah jump with me to to your time at
instacart because i'm sure anybody who's
a tuning in here is immediately going to
want to understand that perspective
instacart is known to be
you know one of those case studies those
hallmarks
companies of fast growth you were the
chief growth officer there for some time
tell me a little bit about that position
for you
yeah no it was it was a great
uh great position and great job and of
course a great company
um that's very successful even today
what was interesting about instacart is
everyone knows about it's fast growth
but what was interesting when i started
is the company was growing
but didn't really understand why
right they didn't really understand what
drove growth
and what stopped growth from happening
there were all these mysteries
you know why was this particular
uh market launch successful
but this one just a week later wasn't
interesting right
why do we stop growing during certain
months of the year
and then certain months we grow super
fast
you know and and i was even brought on
board during a period when growth had
slowed down
the company had spent a few months
focusing on profitability which is very
important when you're in a delivery
business
and were shocked to discover at the end
of their profitability at first that
growth had actually stopped
um you know they were profitable now but
grove had stopped uh and so that was
one of the reasons why i think the
company brought me in because they're
like well we need someone to
re-accelerate growth again right i can't
be a venture-backed company without fast
growth
um
and
really it was an exercise that you know
i've seen at other places which is
to drive growth you actually need to
understand
what makes you grow you need to
understand the system
of growth
right what helps you grow what hurts you
from growing
um and so we spent quite a bit of time
using data primarily right to connect
the dots a little bit more to understand
why instagram was growing and why it
wasn't growing in some cases and then
once we understood it was it was pretty
easy to
double down on the things that were
working and get the company to grow
again
so it can't be as simple as let's just
look at the data make sense of it
and
you know and and and make decisions
based off of that you have to
to really put in some some structured
work in place what what did you find
that that needed to happen
and with your leadership that that
really made the difference in the way
even people think through
data analysis or data synthesis
yeah there were a couple of things um
and so you're right just looking at the
data at a surface level doesn't really
help you with these things you need to
somehow find the deeper insights
and so i'll give you a few things that
that we did that were particularly
successful
one is
pay attention to moments of change
right so in a dynamic organization like
instagram new stuff is happening all the
time right new products are watching new
markets are launching
those moments of change
are actually incredible opportunities to
learn
and you learn more from understanding
that that change point and what happened
then you might from
tons of examination of the overall data
set or the surface level interesting so
i'll give you a i'll give you an example
please right when i was at instacart
you know an effort that started before i
arrived
um you know concluded in the launch of a
new retailer on the platform a new
grocery retailer in florida right the
retailer is publix it's the number one
grocery retailer in florida right
everyone who lives in florida knows
publix right it is very famous
and so that was a moment of change right
i had nothing to do with it the team was
in progress and in launching it
but what you could see
is that there was a clear inflection
in growth
in florida
right literally at that moment in time
at that point of change
and so
that gave us a pretty big clue there's
like maybe there's something
about publix
right that accelerates group what is it
and it's interesting we paid a lot of
attention to that moment and tried to
figure out what is it what what did we
or they or our combination
do
to accelerate growth and can we take
whatever it is
and you know do it for everyone do it
for every market
and it sounded like that behavior turned
out to be pretty successful giving given
what we saw in the in the coming years
we have just a few minutes left elliot
um first i want to mention that um i i
love the
the curiosity that you bring with you to
these different
these different worlds right you're not
you didn't just play a role in these
companies you're talking about your
experiences as a change maker you know
challenging the norms looking at your
own education and your own experiences
and how to
build consistently build this sort of
chain game-changing mentality of okay
this is you know we're doing great sure
but but
if we do this this could be great tell
me about your your most recent startup
now anomalo um which which also has to
do with enterprise data
oh absolutely so as hopefully has been
clear through through our chat
heavy user of data yeah for for nearly
20 years uh i think in a lot of
different companies so i've seen the
value
of being a truly data driven
organization of noticing
when things are changing in your data of
obtaining deep insights
um and so the the vision for anomalo is
to bring that power to more
organization um
and one of the things we saw on
instacart we saw very directly is of
course instacart very sophisticated
data-driven organization lots of people
lots of machine learning experts
you know lots of data flowing in
one of the hardest things in running in
a data-driven way was actually just
monitoring our data and making sure it
was correct
right and making sure nothing crazy was
happening or noticing if something crazy
did happen so we could investigate it
right that was one of the hardest things
and we were kind of hurt time and again
from our data breaking our data
disappearing our data changing in some
crazy way that we didn't expect breaking
lots of other things
so analog is the product i wish i would
have had
well uh get all those roles
as kind of a data-driven product leader
because what a novel can do is they can
connect
to your enterprise data to your data
warehouse
and monitor everything in your data make
sure your data is actually there that
it's consistent
what has come before that it doesn't
have unusual changes or drift
and if it finds any of those things
it can let you know so you can
investigate and you can figure out
what's going on
so the main pain point that i'm
understanding here is this ability to
detecting these changes to detecting
you know those mishaps the changes
the lack of data because it's you know
the classic question here is the
structured versus unstructured approach
and
how do you make sense of data that you
know in a scalable generalized way which
is one of the most difficult
pain points of data decision making
why do you converge that this
specific issue is the most impactful one
that you can create
i mean you could have created any
company
um in any domain at this point why why
this why now
well
it's an area of passion for me as it's
hopefully clear and i i
have achieved a lot of things in my
career as a data-driven leader i want
more leaders and more companies to be
data-driven and achieve the same results
and i'm excited about having the right
tools to truly be data-driven to find
the right insights to be able to
accelerate growth right or improve your
product for whatever you want to do
and this was a real gap
that i saw uh if you think about the
evolution of data in the last 10 years
you know a lot of things that were
hard
when i was you know doing growth at
linkedin and running experiments 10
years ago are pretty easy now you can
have a massive data warehouse in the
cloud that's set up in minutes you can
use a tool like dbt
to transform your data effortlessly
right and create
whatever you need to create to consume
that data you have these powerful
machine learning frameworks that will
allow you to learn from your data
but
this basic idea of who's actually
monitoring your data
to make sure it's correct to make sure
it doesn't have any crazy changes
that you should notice and react to
that really didn't exist
right or or it existed in a way that was
never going to work for example there
are rule-based solutions out there where
you have to define rules for your data
sure do tons of work sure to find
anything and then your data changes in
unexpected ways and your rules don't
work anymore
um and so uh you know both my co-founder
jeremy and i saw this as a huge gap
uh and kind of the data stack the the
set of tools that modern data
practitioners use
and we were excited to solve it
i love it elliott the
the excitement is infectious last
question for you how do you get your the
people with their work with you to share
this passion i get that you've had you
know more than 20 years of experience
dealing with this same problem and it's
crystal clear for you now how do you
get
the you know the people that are working
with you that perhaps don't have that
shared experience to understand the
magnitude of what they're doing
yeah well believe it or not we've been
able to hire a lot of people
that resonated with us with this problem
um you know there's a lot of folks in
every function
that have used data
in their careers and a lot of folks that
have experienced
data failures and data issues
right and issues with the quality of the
data that we're using and those tend to
be so a lot of the folks that get
attracted to a novel because they get
the problem
right maybe they weren't a data
scientist before maybe they weren't a
data-driven leader but they get the
problem sure some experience that
they've had and so they understand why
it's important that we solve it
elliot thank you so much i really really
appreciate your time and your energy and
the intentionality and the insights
and
literally you know looking at the the
whole industry and and that and looking
at it at a pain point that's horizontal
um and um creating not even just a
solution for but creating a new
framework of thinking through the
importance of data and and these
detections so thank you very very much
best of luck with enamel i'm gonna be
cheering from the side and thank you for
the time
thank you so much for having me michael
it's been a pleasure